uh i want to get your perspective on
something not as a father not as a
consumer not as a content creator but as
a ceo because for as long as i've been
doing stuff with valuetainment for the
past few years we've actually applauded
reid hastings for being such a brilliant
ceo right he wrote a book called what no
rules rules yeah right and we've
actually been singing his credit for
years okay so i want you to put your ceo
hat on right now for a second and ask
yourself okay there's they they clearly
are having some sort of board meeting
right now being like all right guys we
during covet 20 20 21
they were on top of the world
the subscribership was up bananas
everyone was on lockdown
up until what six months ago squid game
which i never saw was the biggest
[ __ ] show in the history of
netflix yeah everything yeah
dude you're the man you're the best
you're the best ceo ever and now boom
just like that their stock has dropped
crumbled netflix has basically been kind
of canceled by the market so you as a
ceo what is reid hasten saying right now
he's he's got to be having like a
you know a war room conversation with
his team saying guys huddle up you know
he probably has crisis mode he probably
has a picture of that that pregnant
asian guy and he's like i don't ever
want to see this [ __ ] again so let me do
what i do here's what i just did i just
went on crunch base
and i looked at who sits on their board
it's the first thing i did okay you got
rich barton who sits on their board you
got timothy haley who sits on their
board since 98 you got jay hoke who sits
on the board since 99 you got ann who's
been sitting there since 2010. you got
ann swinney who's been there since 2015
brad smith who's been there since 2015
and then you got mathias dophner who's
been there since 2018 and then he got
reed who's been there since 97. okay
do you remember when the whole thing
happened with twitter and everybody was
bashing you know jack dorsey's this jack
dorsey is that jack towards his digits
it's jack i can't believe jack dorsey
you know kicked a suspended or you know
silenced trump and jack was kind of like
playing the you know neutral side and it
was oh it's all jack dorsey's fault and
then jack dorsey resigns and boom kind
of works his way out i think may's going
to be his last month to be an executive
chairman and a new guy comes in and
takes home like oh [ __ ] jack was
actually not as bad as the new guy is
right the new guy changing him all this
other stuff and now you know uh musk is
talking about potentially buying
uh twitter and in doing so he's thinking
about doing something with dorsey why is
dorsey's name being mentioned again and
something like that so anyways so the
point is i don't know if it's read as a
company gets bigger
you know certain things you no longer
are as involved in especially their
model if you've ever read their book no
rules rules they'll give you a budget
and they'll say go do whatever you want
to buy and you don't even need to get it
approved by us that's their model like
you can go buy a six and a half million
dollar project and you don't even need
to buy the runner by read and a lot of
their c-suites i love that we're going
to start implementing that at
valuetainment i really are so funny
so the point is the point is i don't
know how much of it is him right now but
i can tell you right now
you affected people's pockets there are
people who had five million dollars in
netflix stock and you just cost that
person that had five million dollars in
netflix stock you cost them two million
dollars in a day yeah one day two
million dollars and that person as uh
tyler mutes herself that person who just
lost two million dollars in a day that
person is not sitting on the sidelines
saying oh it's okay reid we trust you no
no no they're getting emails yeah
they're losing their minds they're
calling their broker then morgan's
calling these guys and goldman's
probably already had a call with them
anybody that's given them money they got
there's a lot of difficult calls they're
going through and typically in
situations like this you have to regroup
you have to bring new leadership team in
you got to fire some people you got to
let some people go they've gone they've
gone through this you're saying fire
people from the board how does that work
not not from the board you can't you you
need to bring some new people to the
board they got a they need to add three
more because 11 is an odd number but
there's some moves i'd be making if i
was them but if they don't move too
quickly shit's going to get very ugly
and by the way bank of america is not
even saying to hold so so the market's
not even putting them in the hold
category you know how there's a buy hold
and sell category they're in the cell
category they're not even in the whole
category so people are not even saying
it's over meaning brace for impact it's
going to go lower i didn't say that a
lot of the analysts let me go one step
deeper with you know how we play that
game with uh with a lot of people okay
who are the most important uh yeah um
ceo a board member no no not so much
that like uh universities
uh social media how do you how do you
describe that that's the the most
influential parts of society
what is what is the what are the reasons
the top five reasons that that netflix
is it is because they're they they
you know pander to woke culture is it
because of content is it because of
competition because of paramount disney
and amazon like what are the three or
four reasons that this is happening it
can't just be well their content isn't
that good or because they got a pregnant
guy there's gotta be something you know
what's one of the worst things that
happens to athletes to come i saw a
conor mcgregor video i showed yesterday
in front of the guys and when he says
you know people say a loss is really
going to be bad and
he says let me tell you what's worse
than a loss that can ruin your career a
win
uh when you win you get softer when you
when you show up a little later when you
when you get a little cocky or when you
when you become casual when you win
natural instinct to most people these
guys been winning for too long it's like
how many consecutive quarters have you
been kicking ass yeah you've gotten
cocky you're throwing your weight around
you're like oh we've got the grimey we
got the oscars all right
here's who we are and and the market
just said listen bro chill out
yes you're a billionaire yes you got a
lot of money salute for producing a
great product and putting a company that
almost bought you out for 50 million
bucks blockbuster you put an 8 billion
out but this is capitalism customers
comes first and you just screwed up so
it doesn't matter they royally screwed
up because they've been winning for too
long and maybe the best thing that
happened is an l that they just took
i saw it with comedy central at their i
mean they're still a channel technically
but
they're not famous for their content
their original content now you know i
don't know anything that's on their
network that isn't a re-bought
like they're just running office reruns
now but it wasn't that way back in 2009
2010 i was writing on a show called the
burn with jeff ross uh the roastmaster
general and um
i remember
sitting at the table for one of the our
first like important meetings that we
had to clean up the writer's room for
there were some comedy central execs
coming in like whoopty whoop and they
came in and i remember at one point
literally uh
one of them said the words because
someone had brought up netflix and in
2009 netflix wasn't really like it
wasn't that big of a deal but it was
coming and i think it was even me that
mentioned like you know netflix does
this thing where they don't have
commercials blah blah blah whatever we
were talking about and i remember the
comedy central exec who is since fired
not a board member yeah a regular
executive someone who's supposed to
decide what gets a second season or what
who we should work with and all these
things and i remember him specifically
saying we are comedy central we are the
comedy go-to on cable
and
people will always come back to us can't
be like that no way this is not how
market works you're in the room when
this happens
he was gone two or three years later and
not only is he gone but
and these guys you know again hollywood
they all hire each other's friends i
know he's these guys are all executives
at apple now and here now and netflix
now by the way
because they need people with resumes
that look like they were doing something
but meanwhile they they were sinking the
ship as it was going on they they buried
this show which was hilarious granted
i'm a little bit biased because i was
one of the writers on it but i mean all
these shows that should have been pushed
they hide behind reruns of something for
example you don't get to decide when
if you get picked up you don't get to
decide where your new show goes
executives are making bad decisions
after bad decisions they debut a new
show but they're putting it after reruns
of this old show
and so by putting you in a position
they're
already deciding that you're going to be
canceled because they're going to go
your viewerships down meanwhile you
could put a shitty show after right
after a good show and they get picked up
because the people are already there
your tb was on the channel so it's
harder to turn the channel than it is to
put it on we talked about this during
dinner with joe about disney if you
remember when when
you know a name came up he's like i know
this person i'm not going to mention
what it was but i know this person i
know this person so by the way somebody
just commented in the comment section so
they made me take a look at this ackman
loses more than 430 million dollars in
one day because of that
okay so this is this is when it gets
scary because people like this start
calling when carl icon lost money with
aig do you know what carl icahn did
within two months
every day he bullied the ceo until they
had to they have to fire the c under
still have to step down
guys like this have so much power where
they're making these are the guys you
don't want to piss off like you know how
in russia they talk about putin so who
should put and worry about and what do
they say the family the ugly arcs you
know they're the oligarchs all the
creatures
if they if they say anything you don't
want this is oligarch it's who it is
ackman is part of the oligarch uh if you
if you look at it from that standpoint
but you know you said something and it
made me think about this i've been
processing the understanding of the
meaning of fear in a different way
there's certain words in my life i want
to have i want to have a better
understanding of what this word means
it's always curious about the word lazy
like why are we lazy and you know more i
did i realized okay boredom stems
you know from laziness if somebody gives
a boring joke you're going to become
lazy and your body gets tired great i
want to know what it means to be lazy
but fear
is so confusing because we've been
campaigned with the shirt that we all
wore as kids that said what no
fear no no fear [ __ ] i'm i'm
probably
extremely
afraid and let me explain to you what
what i meant by this so somebody's
asking me the question i'm explaining if
i'm like let me tell you when i go back
and actually pause like you know how we
all say the answer because the right
thing to say and like is that really who
i was yeah let me think
i'm a pretty scared guy and what do you
mean by that i was so afraid of my dad
dying and my kids never meeting him
because i never met my grandma
my name and my grandpa you have no idea
how scared i was at i would have
nightmares in the middle of the night
it's not fear of oh my god i feared this
but it was such a fear that created such
a sense of urgency for me to get to work
because
now that fear is gone because all my
kids know him so well and they love him
they love their grandpa that fear is
gone now the next fear is i don't want
to walk my daughter down the aisle and
she marries a schmuck at that moment
i've given him up giving her up and i'm
like you're an idiot and she chose to
marry you because daddy made some bad
choices and i was lazy and now i have to
deal with a [ __ ] like you i want her to
choose to marry a [ __ ] because she
chose to marry a [ __ ] not choose to
marry a [ __ ] because he makes 60 grand
a year and he's going to supp i don't
want i don't want that to be the reason
from a place of fear right
netflix is not afraid right now and they
should be afraid yeah i think the market
is not afraid right now right when you
get cocky you lose fear you have to be
reminded you need to get scared again if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you